si tomamos un vaso con agua y tenemos
una aguja y tomamos con cuidado esta
aguja poniéndola suavemente por encima
del agua la aguja va a quedar flotando
pero realmente no está flotando ya que
la aguja es más densa que el agua y
sabemos que si es más densa pues se va a
hundir en el agua así que en realidad no
está flotando simplemente está asentada
en la superficie y esto se debe a que
hay una atención superficial en el agua
el agua es un líquido que tiene la
capacidad de tener una cantidad
significativa de atención superficial y
sabemos que esto se debe a la atención
superficial porque si llegamos y metemos
nuestro dedo con un poquito de fuerza
golpeamos la aguja hacia abajo lo
suficiente para romper la atención
superficial la aguja se va a hundir como
si fuera una piedra y como es que el
agua tiene esta propiedad de la atención
superficial tiene que ver con el hecho
de que las moléculas de agua dentro de
este líquido sea
mutuamente esta molécula de agua puede
formar enlaces de hidrógeno con las
demás moléculas de agua que la rodean
y escalada hacia estas hay un término
para esto le llamamos
cohesión el hecho de que las moléculas
de agua y las moléculas de otros
líquidos se atraen mutuamente a esto le
llamamos cohesión y eso qué tiene que
ver con la atención superficial bueno el
chiste es que a estas moléculas de agua
les gusta estar reunidas les gusta
agruparse si pueden esta molécula de
agua como se puede mover pues puede
elegir con cuál de las otras moléculas
agruparse y el problema es aquí adentro
del líquido no puede decidirse con quién
se va a agrupar en otras palabras
digamos que es jalada por esta otra
molécula bueno también va a ser salada a
la izquierda por estas otras moléculas
de acá está la jala hacia su posición
original está también la jala de regreso
a su posición original ya que habrá un
componente de esta fuerza que está
apuntando en la dirección de su posición
original lo mismo con esta molécula a la
izquierda así que las moléculas que se
encuentran adentro del líquido están
restringidas tienen muchas otras
moléculas de agua a su alrededor
dictando en donde deben estar ya que si
tratan de desplazarse van a ser caladas
de nuevo a su posición original sin
embargo en la superficie no hay
moléculas de agua por encima de la
superficie estas moléculas son más
libres y están menos restringidas por lo
que las moléculas de la superficie
pueden agruparse entre sí y formar
enlaces un poquito más fuertes entre
ellas y se agrupan en la superficie de
tal manera que crean una atención la
cual no está presente en la parte de
adentro del líquido esas moléculas de
aquí abajo van a evitar que se agrupen o
se apelmacen en el centro pero ya que
aquí arriba hay menos restricciones
pueden formar estos enlaces más fuertes
en la superficie y eso les permite
soportar cierta tensión de arriba que es
lo que permite que la aguja descanse
sobre la superficie
algunas aplicaciones prácticas de estos
son los estudios clínicos
si hay bilis presente en la orina se
puede detectar su presencia porque baja
la atención superficial de la orina por
lo que nos permite probar cómo se está
comportando el hígado y si está
metabolizando las cosas como debería
otra aplicación es que si ustedes van de
campamento tienen su tienda de campaña
que comienza a llover y en el techo de
la tienda se forman un gotitas de agua
la mayoría de las tiendas de campaña
evitarán que el agua se filtre hacia
adentro pero quizás se sientan tentados
si están sentados cómodamente adentro
decir ahora esto se ve muy padre y lo
quieran tocar pero no deben de tocar las
gotas de agua que están sobre la tienda
ya que en cuanto las toquen pueden
romper la atención superficial y una vez
que rompemos la atención superficial las
gotitas de agua se van a empezar a
filtrar a dentro de la tienda justo
desde el lugar donde lo tocamos y esto
quizás no les haga pasar una buena noche
así que resistan la tentación de tocar
las gotitas de agua y romper la atención
superficial de su tienda de campaña y
también cuando nos lavamos las manos y
usamos jabón si nos lavamos las manos
solamente con agua muchas veces la
atención superficial del agua es muy
grande las moléculas de agua van a estar
muy unidas entre ellas y van a formar
grupos muy grandes aunque no nos lo
parezca podemos ver el agua que está muy
parejito pero a nivel microscópico el
agua no está tan difusa como debería
estar forman grupos ya que el agua tiene
una cohesión que la mantiene unida pero
si agregamos un poco de jabón o de
detergente
esto va a romper la atención superficial
del agua lo que significa que las
moléculas de agua no van a estar pegadas
unas con otras ya no están en grupos tan
grandes puede penetrar más fácilmente
todas las arruguitas y pliegues que haya
en nuestra piel lo que nos permitirá
quitar mejor la mugre
así que la atención superficial se debe
a la cohesión entre las moléculas de
agua que se encuentran en la superficie
del líquido pero las moléculas de agua
no sólo se atraen entre ellas de hecho
son atraídas por el contenedor y otros
materiales y a esto le llamamos adhesión
el hecho de que las moléculas de agua
sean atraídas por otros materiales lo
llamamos adhesión entonces esta molécula
de agua no sólo es atraída por las otras
moléculas de agua que están a su
alrededor sino que también es atraída a
la pared de este contenedor y es por eso
que algunas moléculas de agua suben un
poquito por esta pared del contenedor y
es por eso que vemos cuando llenamos
algún contenedor con agua y estamos
midiendo líquido en una pequeña pipeta
la superficie no va a estar
perfectamente lisa va a tener una forma
más o menos así esto está exagerado pero
el chiste es que a los lados va a estar
un poquito más elevado
está el centro por lo que debemos tener
cuidado al medir líquidos a esto se le
llama el menisco y se debe a la adhesión
o la atracción de las moléculas de agua
al material del contenedor en donde se
encuentra esta fuerza de adhesión es
importante ya que ocasiona algo que
llamamos acción capilar nos deshacemos
de esto y si tenemos un contenedor con
líquido digamos que es agua y tomamos
otro contenedor algo parecido un popote
lo ponemos aquí adentro si lo sumergimos
veremos que debido a que el líquido es
atraído por las paredes de este
contenedor no solamente se va a quedar
en este nivel se va a subir oa levantar
por encima del nivel original del agua
si tuviéramos otro contenedor tipo
popote más pequeño en diámetro y lo
pusiéramos aquí mientras más pequeño sea
el tubo mayor será este efecto y veremos
que el agua se eleva a un nivel mucho
mayor que el que tenía originalmente
dentro de este popote y esto es debido a
la adhesión del agua con las paredes de
este contenedor y el nombre de este
efecto es acción capilar la cual es
importante en una variedad de ejemplos
biológicos y no biológicos en donde al
fluido se le ayuda a transportarse en
parte debido a esta atracción entre el
líquido y las paredes del contenedor o
del tubo en donde está fluyendo